[Music]
this week we've got queensguard hot
cheetos and bad 9-1-1 call queensguard
was that you know the in Australia the
ones that don't smile the ones that
stand in front of the over the furry
hats Buckingham Palace is it true that
you could stand in front of them and do
whatever they ain't gonna move no
because you can't touch on in [ __ ] yeah
if you touch them they yell at you it's
crazy there's all these videos of them
saying like don't disturb the Queen's
Guard or some [ __ ] like that but they
know the Queen's God they yell in your
face or like they'll do these marches
and if people are in the way don't
[ __ ] trample through them it looks
dull mmm so this video went viral
recently of it one of queen's guardsmen
at the windsor castle where there's this
tourist where she clearly crossed the
rope oh she got tackled please soldier
was marching got bitch-slap they don't
stop for you man I love this [ __ ] oh
that's not even that bad it looks like
they set that up no that [ __ ] was out
of line
nearly yeah she went over the rope she
was just standing in the way of this
dude that was Mark IV she just didn't
know where she was that Oh Bichette you
have to step over there oh yeah how do
you get over I've seen like tourists
where they're just [ __ ] stupid like
they just don't get it like remember and
you were you there no over the rope in
Hawaii there was that was this [ __ ]
um in why you can't touch these Turtles
like these big-ass
Turtles right but there's no ropes and
fun the turtles there is there are rules
yeah there are there's caution tape that
they put around you guys there when that
Korean dude got its fat ticket no well
actually heels gotta be in dumbass so
you wanted to get closer to the turtle
so he kept kicking the rope dude badass
fine dude it's like huge - it's $5,000
fine to touch the turtle it's like
something ridiculous yeah basically it's
for like if you're rich you can touch
them yeah but some stupidity
so it's for the elite yeah basically
I'll do whatever I want
just touch him that lady she stepped
over a rope
yeah she clearly I like that I like when
it's Instant Karma
that makes mojo satisfied I watched this
video like 30 times what I would have
wanted to see is like a bayonet go
through her chest legitimately I thought
he was gonna kick her in the [ __ ] like
the way he was walking because his legs
were going like this
I thought he wasn't go between the dress
and kick her in the [ __ ] yeah okay we
watch the other ones I don't know yeah
foot movement [ __ ] keep out of the way
HS it looks setup to me though Oh like
base like she set it up like whoever
somebody's standing they're filming her
as the guys walking she's standing there
yeah it's a little bit like well what's
going on here bu is only because it's
changing of the guards or whatever he
was like oh I'm on I remember this
moment
yeah because there's a ton of tourists
they're already filming it's interesting
cuz like he um right but what is she
doing though
she's taking a photo like a selfie or
something thinking of phone or maybe
that lady crossed over and he was like
oh [ __ ] I wonder what's gonna happen oh
oh it's true that's pretty dope you've
crossed the rope it happens he's not
even angry that there's like no emotions
just he's doing a job yeah can we watch
make way for the Kingsguard can we watch
the compilation and he's British see the
Bristol play yeah yeah the British like
colonized all the whole world
they can easily colonize that lady that
lays the lucky there's in a [ __ ] you
know the Queen's property now a new
country on her back every time see a
Torah spoken to his neighbors and taxing
that back to yeah dude they'll tax that
bag dude [ __ ] tariffs all overnight
ass
I could have a port between your legs in
an hour yeah people don't [ __ ] play
to the British named after some British
last name let's watch this [ __ ] but this
I love this [ __ ] Queens ass now you
could watch this at home but it's the
best
you never said this to me bro I like
this [ __ ] watch watch they're gonna get
ran over look I love this [ __ ] actually
working dude that was the most dramatic
scream for a bag I've ever heard in my
life they got you with them watch watch
watch watch he's gonna get run over but
did it think that that in America
everybody'd be like it so the Army's
horrible like Everett you know I'm
saying like yeah yeah he'll be so Lord
you got in the way of a freaking
somebody with a gun you're an idiot
true I saw one recently where this guy
they were so they were marching into the
same castle and then they turn around to
close the gate but the tourists got in
the way or he got too close and then the
guy was like my boy or movie I forgot
myself but the guy his immediate
reaction was huh so you could watch this
later but there's another compilation
where they get into the [ __ ] tourists
face like this close oh and then they
make them [ __ ] fall and all this [ __ ]
cuz people [ __ ] around way too much Wow
yeah somebody deserves to die sometimes
all the time we don't need everybody
exact I say that all the time
yep that's that we're friends it's a
really good teacher we don't need
everybody yeah somebody deserve to die
sometimes we don't need everybody that
they speak we'll think they just keep
everybody in America like huh
we don't need a lot of people are doing
[ __ ] man you got to go yeah where do we
send them I don't know you know
somewhere you're gonna like Joe Mallya
oh really yeah is that a new place what
do you do with extra people
what do you do they don't renew Anglin
note senator bob we just burned the
unuseful ones wow that's good yeah well
make someone useful yeah windershins
huh your emotions today I feel like you
it's random it's like bingo bingo your
burn it's like ancient Oh
everyone's gonna move out that no but my
friends will be okay I mean that's how a
dictatorship works you know your friends
and families all good and everybody else
I don't know where I stand in that bunch
cuz sometimes I'm your friend since you
already have a high position you're the
[ __ ] the administrator of pets Oh pets
in the restaurant sounds about right
[ __ ] administrative fat f AP yeah I
cried next sorry there's this fat Queen
[ __ ] administrator of feds I'm so
slow yeah I got it my lollipop this mom
from Memphis who's warning everyone
after her daughter's gallbladder was
removed because she ate so many hot
snacks she doesn't need it warned people
we [ __ ] know this [ __ ] you [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] that's obvious [ __ ] I mean a
PSA with hot snacks directly attack your
gallbladder yeah too much of anything
attacks some part of you you mean like
flaming hot cheetos and hot fries cool
your digestive system goes like wherever
you called that isn't I think it creeps
like those scones right because all
stumps I think the real question is
what's a gallbladder yeah yeah let's
start with that right
that produces a pile like those in China
let's ask an even bigger question that
it's a soup seasoning over there we
gotta break this mistletoe in China I'll
kiss you under the gallbladder I knew I
had to tell everybody about it Craighead
chips like hot cheetos talkies and hot
fries
we're behind her 17 year old daughter's
stomach problems it's a very plain house
damn her earrings are dope stupid cuz I
want their solos yeah I brought them
back and she was thinking big bags take
him to school with her I was very
surprised that my daughter was sitting
on a big mouth
great more highs didn't estimate cheese
what is drugs
[ __ ] dub sackful yeah bro Paco that was
V in high school that's all I ate they
were like just Hot Cheetos and candy and
maybe like I'm almost I'm almost 100%
sure though it wasn't the hot snack
specifically it was those talky
specifically these are battery acid dude
talkies Oh God you [ __ ] do that
when I first came to LA right and we
were like sharing the [ __ ] that we like
he goes you like hot cheetos you haven't
had takis Wow I ate that [ __ ] ulcers in
my mouth instantly yeah like what the
[ __ ] is this dude
oh yeah sexually transmitted to a lot of
the my friend got takis from a couple of
rows and but it looked just like that
Aki's are so good have you ever tried it
with lime and Tapatio oh yeah do that
[ __ ] already [ __ ] limey and spicy
that's why it's disgusting cuz it's bomb
I love hot cheetos I love that [ __ ] but
then these days when I eat a bag I start
getting sad do you really satellite the
diet yeah it makes me feel weird
yes
- kinda hurts cuz it's not food that's
why yeah your body knows bro the only
time it makes me sad is when I [ __ ] and
then it's just all spicy yeah like talk
even legit if you just crushed it down
you could season a steak with it that's
how salty it is like [ __ ] ridiculous
man
that's just so good that's crazy I have
one through this that's a pick-up line
dude it seems like in that girl's town
what's her kids eat all that job and I
guess every mother does I get it now cuz
it's 17 she's not really a kid right cuz
I initially had thought it was a kid
time i dub but now 17 year old you can't
really control what the hell are you
right there to see yeah I mean she buys
every time she goes out she fights
through it with a big bag and she'll eat
like four of those big ones jammed I
mean now today sorry a week but a lot of
people trust a grocery store though like
they they think anything that you can
consume and buy there is fine it's just
food they don't see ingredient on the
serving size yeah but those serving size
are both no one piece of who are they
based on yeah
I've ever tried the serving size is not
even a human amount rat amount yeah
look if you like she don't eat one
certain size it's like four of them yeah
who the [ __ ] eats for these things and
its owners its Vegas I got one handful
yeah that's on sale but it's very
unspecific you know I'll be any for the
[ __ ] french fries yeah it's like two
six year old hand pulls and they're like
that's not ah let's have a real amount
yeah but that's how Asian people measure
[ __ ] though man it's soup - yeah she
always goes like this she goes when you
make rice it's a one finger indent I was
like look at your [ __ ] tiny ask me to
look at mine now how the [ __ ] does that
translate yeah rice Wars day she's like
this and I'm like mines way bigger than
yours yeah alright for our last story
there was this man from Louisiana who
called the police I'm not right there
mm-hmm one of the best born the big 50
good state one of the top 50 states
I think rated by everybody okay what
does only 50 so husband now rated by the
US Constitution I think I just want to
go to Cafe Du Monde do you really like
desserts
I want to go yet get the beignets and
the coffee I could see you even being a
ZnO yeah
what does he look like yeah it's
powdered up you know and he's got those
desert arms you got desert ons where
it's like because it's like yeah you got
those arms that are kind of working in
wordly oh close and they're close that's
true I do have short or long arms you
got to reach for and I've got a catch
handle this desert arms you got things
you get your hurts are right there look
at him it's cute thank you thank you
like it that's like you like music yeah
yeah that's sanction sin son son team I
don't even know what he's saying mom's
from Okinawa I said what is it I think I
know what you're talking about
Kyle had a bullet he was like somebody
save me you might be saying I really
wanted this baby to I was like he's
right it sounds what is it like a stand
up you might be saying a shamisen maybe
that's it yeah yeah it's um yeah it's
like a base kind of like you play it
it's like it's like a three string
guitar and it go think anything needs
yeah when old guys drink a lot somebody
breaks one out it's like a it's like a
Japanese banjo yes yeah but then the
thing is like a snakeskin at the end
oh is that the thing the geishas play
and [ __ ] hmm I think that's [ __ ] brother
and they stick right after that might be
a quote oh I don't know [ __ ] man I gotta
do my Google searches yeah all the Asian
instruments are always out of tune
though oh that's in tune it's all the
black keys on the piano it was so crazy
about the show we're ignorant about
everything even our own culture
[ __ ] it's sunken it's what Sanchez
actually sent you guys are racist brah I
thought I'm recovering racist I'm gonna
groove alright so anyway so there's
Louisiana man he called 911 because he
wanted to know if he had any warrants
out for his arrest
well it's good idea he called the call
or that resveratrol 9-1-1 which is like
only for emergency it's like a database
your pipe alright but then they
connected to it like if this is an
emergency and you go no and then they're
like hold on and then they switch you up
really station you just call the police
think they should have that you know a
lot a lot of people know that I don't
even know the police stations number I
don't know so if I want to talk about
some normal [ __ ] like a cat is in a tree
I can't do that I only know 9-1-1 so you
it will be kind of helpful if the police
stations start giving out their numbers
in an easier way yeah I mean there's
yeah yeah you have it on your phone yeah
but that's too hard
who's doing that you know the people who
work the front desk at a police station
are they also officers sometimes do like
cadets or whatever they get pissed if
you call though I notice that did the
police have you callin they're like [ __ ]
they do not want to deal with that [ __ ]
yeah they just want to chill out you
want to do volleyball a lot of there
yeah police league volleyball yeah yeah
so this guy though since so they asked
him do you know the difference between
an emergency and a non emergency phone
call and he said yes so then he was
arrested on a charge of misusing the 911
system what so that answers this
question then yeah now he does have a
but I see why it's an emergency
this is Christian oh wow sorry Christian
from Alaska to him they got him from
this yeah Louisiana OH what was he
trying to do again like I don't know if
there were any warrants out for his
arrest
so I'm like were you just trying to get
warm orange calm Rico typing or social
that's like the wrong place to call I
always feel like whenever I get pulled
over from up like a cop pulling me over
I always feel like what if they find a
warrant but I just didn't know about so
I see where he's coming back happened to
me
what happened so when we first started
dating I thought I knew who he was we
were just driving coming back at like in
and out or something like 1:00 a.m. in
the morning and then III ran a stop sign
and the cop pulled me over and I thought
I was just gonna I was gonna get a
ticket and they come out and really
actually sir you have a warrant and then
he made me get out and then handcuff me
and sit me on the curb no warrant was it
was a code from another city and all the
codes in every city are different
worried and I was like what the [ __ ] and
I was thinking back like I used to
commit hella crimes I was like 15 but I
don't remember doing anything bad in a
long time and then so he had to book me
he took me back of the police car took
me to like know yeah and then I'm just I
don't even know what's happening they
make me take my clothes off and then I
have to go sit and make you take your
clothes off one of my panties sure this
wasn't a bachelor party cop strippers in
[ __ ] you're under arrest boy dude that's
a great way to get out of a date though
obviously he didn't let me at the date
you know sit guys pull me over put the
cuffs on me and let's [ __ ] go to Vegas
yeah and then he took me in and then
later on after four hours they called
the police station the one where the
code was from and they found out it was
just my I didn't pay the registration on
my dog your dog on Tyson I didn't pay
the registration on Tyson for like a
year
Wow and then so that turns into
collections I can get amazing you buy a
dog there's a [ __ ] BIG's a lot of it
and I see that but over a [ __ ] dog
citation can't believe you registered
your dog what Asian does that do that's
looking wild I've never heard that
that's why they got a city never seen my
parties we don't do
never registered my dog the Golding dogs
no dude build that fence that's what I'm
saying bro we got to keep these dogs out
of this country you know I'm saying
they're unregistered if you don't let's
say one of your cats fight someone and
again well worth they get out they catch
them they'll incinerate them immediately
Oh Santa rate them who is it groove who
works in your neighborhood is it grew
from [ __ ] and [ __ ] Despicable Me
put them down like immediately because
cat doesn't belong to anybody they just
think it's a stray yeah he's mine but
they just put them up you put them in a
shelter it's a high kill shelter to be
specific and they are all high kill
shelters except for like a couple in the
hood yeah they're like Burnham Larry
literally cats and I first its grill him
up Thursday hit a lot of the same it's
[ __ ] ladies night at a lot of these
places dude wow man I can't believe you
guys have to go through so much as pet
owners it's intense huh
you know holy pets mm-hmm well you
that's what normal people do but most
people don't do that though yeah they
just have pets wait so that means they
never take them to the vet
cuz they take them well if you're dead
oh no you know me check ya know you just
get it off the Craigslist so you just
like you're in a parking lot and this
guy's selling puppies for 20 bucks and
you get one and you keep it and Dodge
Neon puppies boy just keep the puppy and
that's it it is the dog dies no you
never look but you never have to show
that at the vet have you seen Old Yeller
though did you guys know about that yeah
it's not a racist term it's a movie that
they had when I was growing up no no I
remember I used to have the VHS man oh
oh yeah come back they said that rabies
they couldn't afford to feed like just a
couple like there's like some different
like man I cried at this conspiracy's
mine that shit's conspiracy oh yeah
seriously dude it's deep the web is day
when they had to put them out now I die
[ __ ] chronic little [ __ ] like a
little [ __ ] I [ __ ] cried I had the
VHS so I I knew what was gonna happen
but every time I was hoping that
something else would happen cuz but
wasn't
so good yeah it's a good inch I don't
know what would have happened like the
dog litter here and you see the smoke
come out from behind uh all yellow
wasn't a Disney movie whoa it's not a
Disney movie as a kid though it is it is
a kid movie but it is yeah it was a
Disney Productions why it's a Disney
movie at least the one I saw or I know
about because it's not a cartoon it's
live but it is still be a Disney film
though the only reason why I know that
it is cuz I had the Disney sing-along
[ __ ] VHS tapes sing-along to a dog
getting murdered made it no from that
movie I was gonna come back if his dead
no but that's the intro song and then
with the insult and then the [ __ ]
doggy comes in yellow every [ __ ] time
I was hoping something else would happen
you okay if I was like this time God is
gonna come and [ __ ] rescue him and
cure him but it always happens man I
[ __ ] hate this Panasonic VCR
goddammit I think it's high brothers
they say that high well I remember dude
that's why you guys both to remember
that Disney movie that much cuz I
watched it too I remember the movie I
just not the song Wow
[Music]